eu não sei se vocês já pararam para
pensar mas parece que a gente não sabe
mas como é que é se relacionar de
verdade com a comida que chega na nossa
mesa e muito pouco tempo o que era
baseado em cultura e funcionalidade
passou a ser uma relação frágil que pra
mim deixa a nossa sociedade à beira de
um colapso perigoso e potencialmente
reversível pra onde a gente está indo e
o quanto a gente está realmente
preocupado com esse problema moderno com
essa verdade inconveniente
meu nome é eduardo e eu estou aqui hoje
porque eu quero mudar a forma como as
futuras gerações se conectar com a
comida e pra mim essa revolução ela tem
que começar agora esse lindão aí o
francisco meu filho ele tem nove meses e
uma pergunta comum lá em casa é o que o
chico vai comer quando crescer eu queria
repetir essa pergunta aqui pra vocês o
que você quer comer quando crescer
isso é bom é isso mesmo o que está por
trás dessa pergunta tem um famoso
relatório que diz que a geração do
francisco essa galera toda aqui nasceu
depois dos anos 2000 é a primeira
geração da história em que a expectativa
de vida dos filhos
ela é menor do que a dos pais isso mesmo
gente esse bonitão aqui ele pode viver
menos do que eu tem diversos motivos que
levam esse cenário e mas eu quero focar
no que eu considero mais importante que
de uma certa forma envolve todos nós
também que a alimentação podem ficar
tranqüilos que uma notícia péssima como
essa também tem falado bom como toda
notícia é a gente tem visto surgir em
todo mundo o movimento a favor da comida
de verdade é com o intuito de acabar com
esse mal pela raiz
estou muito nervoso cheio com muita
alegria que faz parte desse movimento
ela não aparece aqui e eu tô aqui pra
dividir um pouco essa história com o cd
é para a gente imaginar então como é que
você os próximos 50 anos
eu quero bandeirantes chegar até lá eu
preciso voltar um pouco no tempo para
vocês entenderem
a gente chegou até aqui eu vou voltar 50
anos neste momento é o fim de um grande
período de guerra um período longo de
guerra e pode se dizer que a vida estava
começando a voltar a ser como era antes
é basicamente é quando se pensa em
alimentação era possível comer a mesma
coisa e da mesma forma que as pessoas
vinham comendo de geração após geração
de regra geral isso quer dizer que cada
lugar como vocês podem ver tinha o seu
traço cultural enraizado na comida das
pessoas e tinha o entendimento de que
como era de fato macaco social fazia
parte
no momento da cultura de cada povo não à
toa
é neste momento as mães representavam o
que tinha de mais importante é para
transmitir esse legado dos hábitos
culturais para as futuras gerações
graças a elas as mães as pessoas sempre
comeram comida de verdade
obrigado mãe conceito que hoje começam
ao mundo como comida local alimentação
orgânica diversidade de produção eram
basicamente a realidade daquele daquele
dia a dia naquele tempo por exemplo as
pessoas comiam as pessoas elas tinham
que comer algo que era produzir
localmente é obrigado a respeitar essa
finalidade
os produtores no campo eles não se chama
cultura esse conceito e lixo que
produzir o máximo de variedades possível
para algumas delas vingar e conhecer a
mente que eles tinham em mãos é
e o que chegava no mercado era fruto
dessa relação era comida de verdade que
vinha precificando dessa proximidade
dessa aproximação com o campo por conta
disso é hoje a gente come por conta
dessa distância dessa barreira hoje a
gente come mais carne - de verdura mas
alimentos processados mas desculpa mais
óleos vegetais e menos gordura animal
mas alimentos processados - natura mas
embalagem bonita - fruta feia a gente
está se preocupando com as coisas
erradas e é isso tudo aconteceu em menos
de 50 anos foi muito pouco tempo pra uma
revolução que aconteceu na nossa comida
na comida do homem moderno e você deve
estar se perguntando então como é que
pouca gente em tão pouco tempo chegou
até aqui né
tem uma frase que responde a essa
pergunta é há muito dinheiro envolvido
na dieta moderna ocidental quem disse
isso foi o jornalista michael pollan que
é um dos maiores estudiosos do assunto e
uma das fontes da minha pesquisa e do
meu negócio também o tollan afirma que
há muito dinheiro envolvido na dieta
humana do natal porque quanto mais se
processa qualquer alimento mais
lucrativo ele se torna para quem está na
ponta final dessa cadeia e quem está lá
atrás colocando a mão na terra não tem
mais quase nenhum controle mas não poder
nessa nova cadeia que cresceu e surgiu
com o intuito de dar conta de alimentar
o mundo todo quem nunca ouviu essa frase
que nunca repetiu essa frase por aí
pena que a gente está muito longe dessa
realidade é segundo a onu hoje no mundo
um sexto da população passa fome
além de toda aquela cultural que essa
indústria comida processada promoveu é a
gente começa a ver um problema que é
surreal para mim inédito mesmas pessoas
que sofrem ao mesmo tempo de sobrepeso e
desnutrição coisas que nunca andaram
juntas ou seja a comida não só não se
tornou mais acessível que as pessoas
continuam passando fome como onde ela
chega ela não é tão legal assim
e isso sem contar o que a gente não vê
né é aqui no brasil cada um de nós cada
pessoa daqui consome em média cinco
litros de agrotóxico por ano é o maior
consumo de ingredientes químicos do
mundo foi um resumo bem resumido e
praticamente mal explicado
esse foi o caminho que levou a geração
do meu filho é a primeira da história a
expectativa de vida menor do que a dos
pais
mas eu comecei falando que não seria só
notícia ruim então chega de ser de graça
é imaginar então como é que você os
próximos 50 anos essa revolução que a
gente quer fazer eu quero fazer uma
outra pergunta que se fosse possível
estabelecer elos perdidos ainda pouca
mencionei comida local alimentação
orgânica e diversidade de produção
eu acho que está clara a tendência
desses movimentos ganharam o mundo já
existem diversas iniciativas destes
movimentos com o trazendo soluções
diferentes para esse mesmo problema da
comida
o que falta ainda infelizmente
engajamento mas eu acredito que quando
as pessoas entenderem o real problema da
industrialização tudo isso que aconteceu
nos últimos 50 anos foi tão ruim
elas vão se sentir parte desse processo
sabe vão querer se conectar de alguma
forma com o movimento da comida de
verdade é por isso que estou aqui e é
por isso que a participação de vocês da
sociedade é mais do que urgente é
necessário boa notícia não precisa de
muito para tornar isso possível eu sou
carioca já perceberam e a gente começou
um desses movimentos que quebra a lógica
convencional do mercado é só usando a
vontade das pessoas
eu sou co fundador do clube orgânico e a
gente faz com que pessoas da cidade
possam se conectar a produtores locais
através de uma e receber através de uma
assinatura anual né eles recebem em casa
ou no ponto de retirada próximo da
própria comunidade
uma cesta de alimentos orgânicos frescos
e sazonais
toda semana tem um compromisso envolvido
a lógica a idéia dessa proposta é
quebrar a distância que existe entre a
cidade eo campo e entregar comida de
verdade pra mesa de gente de verdade
através de um modelo mais justo e
sustentável para as pessoas e para o
planeta
sabe que é legal é o agente não inventou
nada de novo aqui e mesmo assim eu tô no
palco do táxi o que a gente fez foi
inspirada em um modelo chamado ceesay
semcias essenciais são comunidades que
sustenta a agricultura não sei se alguém
já ouviu mas é esse modelo existe desde
o pó de cimento do pós guerra começou no
japão e onde existem milhares de ser
aceite pelo mundo há apenas um numeroso
é esses projetos ele geralmente conectam
um pequeno grupo de pessoas apenas um
produtor o que a gente está fazendo de
diferente aqui e que eu acho que é muito
especial é a gente está adaptando a esse
modelo usando a tecnologia para que ele
possa ser replicado em qualquer lugar
com a mesma estrutura ea gente fala
impactar as pessoas falando impacto eu
queria dividir com vocês o que a gente
conseguiu esse período de um ano foram
mais de duas mil pessoas participando em
duas cidades diferentes com o apoio de
25 agricultores que entregaram incríveis
45 toneladas de alimentos que
simplesmente não teriam chegado na
cidade se não fosse essa parceria
o que eu mais gosto desses números é que
graças à união dessas pessoas a gente
poupou o uso de mais de mil litros de
agrotóxico no campo
aliás abriu agora
hoje é um dia especial pra gente está
completando um ano de parceria com o
primeiro produtor da rede
o davi sorrentino esse rapaz simpático
lá no sítio do coqueiro que é o sentido
da vida
ele passou a ser lucrativo e ele pode
investir em equipamentos novos estufa
trator a as pessoas passaram como vocês
podem ver se envolver mais com a comida
delas
mas mais do que isso gente elas passaram
a se envolver
é com esse produtor kassin homem da
terra no rio vocês já ouviram isso aqui
mas no rio existe uma idéia de que é o
alimento orgânico é difícil é caro e de
difícil acesso provavelmente já ouviu
isso também é o que eu acho que a gente
está acostumado é uma lógica de cada vez
mais pagar menos pelos produtos sabe
independente do impacto que isso vai ter
na cadeia como toda a cadeia grande o
que o movimento da comida de verdade faz
ele inverte essa lógica para que a gente
possa oferecer o melhor elemento que
existe de forma justa e sustentável para
as duas pontas da cadeia
a idéia é muito simples a gente quer que
todo mundo sai ganhando é o consumidor e
produtor de natureza e falando natureza
é tem um estudioso de nutrição no início
do século passado há mais de 100 anos
ele teve uma ideia bastante
revolucionários e eu queria dividir uma
delas com vocês o estã price
ele disse que a alimentação nos liga à
terra e aos seis elementos bem como
desliga a energia do sol
a frase é bem forte é o que a gente tem
vivido hoje o que ele já naquela época
mais de 100 anos chamava de disfunção
ecológica
deixa eu explicar para vocês a idéia é
que existe uma ligação natural do trade
e começa lá com a energia do sol vem pro
solo passa pra nossa comida e chega até
a gente
a disfunção ecológica quando a
industrialização quebre esse processo
e você não tem mais essa ligação natural
por isso que eu afirmo aqui pra vocês
que não é a indústria que alimenta gente
que alimenta gente de verdade é a
natureza
se você vai para a cozinha e prepara o
seu próprio prato de comida você vive
isso na prática quando se vocês saírem
hoje daqui e chegar em casa e se
perguntarem se cada um de vocês aqui se
perguntar quem é que fez a comida que
tarde onde vem a comida que está no meu
prato
isso pra mim é mostra que você se
preocupa mas mais do que isso que você
se importa se importa como remilton que
entrega as saladas saudáveis a preços
populares em comunidades carentes
diversos lugares do brasil se importa
como o thiago que repensar junto da
comunidade local o que consumir
localmente realmente significa uma
cidade do tamanho do rio se importa como
o antoninho que vem mostrando pra europa
que essas grandes redes de supermercado
elas não estão com nada a gente junto
pode muito mais
importa também como herman que largou
tudo na alemanha e veio para o interior
de são paulo mostrará que criar novas
comunidades de apoio à agricultura
usando a arte como ferramenta
hoje já tem até um país inteiro que
mostrou que se importa de verdade com
esse movimento
e eu queria então fazer um convite pra
vocês porque vocês não vai fazer
diferença com a gente também
começa na sua cozinha da sua casa um
trato de cada vez porque pra mim não
importa se você está do lado de quem
produz de quem vende hoje quem compra
até onde eu sei todos comemos e aí já
pensaram que vocês querem comer quando
crescer
obrigado